hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde
survival games zusammen mit genau hier
steht der typ vor mir das beste aber
nicht nur das ist toto die 99 laut
seinem namen zu urteilen ist der 14
also ja so das geburtsdatum time
remaining 30 sekunden auch der tecdax
noch kurz was sagen okay also wir sind
auf die hilfe kann man spezielle
spielprinzipien spielen und wir können
uns jetzt entscheiden zu stellen so wie
übrigens ein steam vereinen und so bei
williams 2 jetzt ist egal sagte das team
scheint okay mach zwei
wir sind drin
ja ich spiele übrigens 1.5 und was sie
noch ganz gut sagen muss bevor du hier
weiterhin kannst fiete wies am berge
sagt kommt das nächste mal samstagabend
und deswegen habe ich jetzt heute also
heute ist donnerstag und freitag an so
pvp sachen vorbereiteter so könnt ihr
euch dann einfach an schuppan an
schuppen und ich glaube ich habe dass
wir simon gilt sehen es geht sofort pvp
los oder opel
ich weiß nicht ich sehe da vorne auf den
pisten ist das auch okay das heißt aber
wir müssen jetzt eigentlich sofort
aufpassen weil wir ja keine friedens
phase haben heißt es könnte sein dass
ich sofort angegriffen werde
erfahrungspunkte
ich glaub ich hab den ton von minecraft
über über außen über außen lautstärke
aber das eigentlich egal weiß ob wunder
sound ist aber okay das killer erklimme
gerade einen berg kellerkind ich bin auf
den berg da direkt daneben direkt
daneben
ich sehe ich nicht aber
hier ist gerade auch so ein typ der es
direkt neben mir der stop me dass dieser
toto die der am anfang schon vor mir
stand ich hatte da ist als ob die beiden
so normal auf nicht gehen die sehen doch
meinen namen wieder die blödmänner
okay okay ich bin ich weg vor so leuten
alter [ __ ] is ticking nitro fakt ist ich
muss weg im alter sorgen was in der
mitte
ok
kann man sich ihn nicht irgendwie den
namen ändern oder so ist das nicht
möglich
ja okay ich bin tot wäre wäre ich sehe
ich seh nix ich seh nix im chat okay gut
was jetzt muss ich wieder kompass
rechtsklick hast du hast kein
expectation und wie komme ich dazu weg
aus dieser lobby na da bist du genau
ok und wie ok
das g 14 okay wenn der inhalt dann
da kann man machen oder wenn im 2 ich
weiß nicht also mach mal baut baut zwei
einfach die gewünschte zweifel games 12
die ist das ist doch diese map im wald
dauert ja weil das ist eine map die
kenne ich auch noch so und survival
games fünf kenne ich auch kann ich jetzt
nicht in meinem namen ändern oder so
kann ich nicht auch man habe auch ich
bin drin
naja egal egal da ich weiß nicht ich
hoffe diesmal aber auch ich glaube
diesmal auch in die mitte was heißt das
was heißt es wenn der typ neben mir so
blöd und am boden
das stinkt
oder comic ist auch dass da oben sind
die flugzeuge das sah das eher cool
gemacht
könnt ihr mich erwähnen
wir sagen jetzt nicht benny 106 2003
dich erwähnen wir bestimmt nicht ich
werde gleich wieder von so einer masse
von zehn leuten getötet die du gehst
rechts und links okay okay okay ich habe
schwer ich habe schwer und ich hab
schuhe
ab 1 gekillt
die längen alle gerade bei mir ja er ist
mir am meisten an die leute kein schwert
an einfach drauf schlagen
ich bin hier in den sommer
ich habe noch eine kiste da sind schuhe
was zu essen und soja bleibt gut ich bin
eigentlich relativ normal ausgerüstet
kann man nicht pilzen mitnehmen wo bis
dahin gelaufen
da ist so eine sonne brücke so eine
steinige brücke irgendwo mehr kannst du
siehst du die em wie ok wartet das erst
mal tief dem greift erst mal an die
fackeln die fackel anzahl die donumenta
ist klingt wenn du so denkst was habe
ich herausgefunden
ach so ja das habe ich aber immer in
meinem vorstellungsvideo von snapshot
habe ich das aber schon herausgefunden
und ich kann auch die veränderung da
bist du ich hab ich hab so sachen und so
war die kandier das geben
so bin ich ja also ich hab doch noch 22
pilze ein steak und ein normales dings
wir werden verfolgt was hat er denn für
sachen
okay wir jetzt erstmal weg in sachen
jammern ich geb dir mein ich gebe dir
mein ziel auf jeden fall des tot aber
der lebt dort noch im wasser der mann
erst jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich im
wasser her okay ja aber ich bin jetzt im
wasser
naja ich hab das steinschmätzer dahin
sind zwei namen da hinten sind zwei
namen der hat ja beide keine sachen
glaube ich ihm keine sache die es noch
eine kiste man auch schon welche ja auf
jeden fall
gerade immer so ein bisschen wacklig
immer rum im boden
ja okay geht es besser das sind typ der
datenbogen
solche nahkampf gehen ich gehe drauf auf
denen der läuft weg der hat nun gold
wert alter der wert gelegt fakt ist
gelegt ich schaffe das wohl schon allein
an bist du okay ja ich laufe da ein
bisschen links von dem umstand dass er
egal
jan o
ja der liegt war das wusste hin ok den 1
der eine ist tot
ich hab eine hose ich hab natürlich wenn
man jetzt nicht einfach auf mein freund
heute muss man aber battle wird machen
willst obwohl schlecht und für nein du
hast gedacht ich bin schlecht
du hast gemeint ich mir schnell aber
gemeint aber gemein
das ist gemeint ist musst du so bist du
hin wo bist du und du bist du
da sind zwei leute im wasser schwimmen
weg von uns wo bist du
ich kenne die hose gehen ja wo bist du
das hatte ihr nach hause ich möchte
jetzt in rosa hinter da liegt die videos
an
ok jetzt gehen auch den oft aber kein
schwert der lutscher wieso geht auf mich
drauf der hat gesperrt beide drauf ich
bin ich habe ihn getötet ich habe
getötet der richtig der hat richtig
viele sache gehabt ich kann gar nicht
alles inventar niemand alter der war
richtig schlecht man sagte mir nicht
getötet man hat richtig viele sachen
dennoch boten alles gesagt ich schaffe
das ich schaff das du
auf jeden fall so ich geh jetz auch
relativ schnell in der mitte da unten
ist noch einer den kann ich erst mal
versuchen anzugreifen
du hast das gesehene
ja sag ich dachte ich könnte jetzt mit
schwert abschießen oder so ich bin kein
guter schütze der tt gut
ja ich schwimmbad nur ein bisschen
weiter weg weil ich nicht so viel leben
habe ja egal sondern machen ja ich habe
aber neue herzen verloren
der schnee schaffen ich hoffe nicht
wobei mir beim elektro beim electric ich
gerade ich habe richtig viel addex in
minecraft 1.5 hat dreieinhalb aber der
schwimmt auf weg
roger aber ich bin zu weit weg ich kann
ich nicht schlagen wie dumm ist das denn
neben mir gibt mir alle meine sachen
seine sachen weil er in so verschonen
soll jetzt geht er wahrscheinlich so an
land und dann springt er wieder zurück
und büsche schlagen
weder der kreis noch mal machen
denn der der springt ins wasser ich bin
gleich ins wasser hundertprozentig jetzt
jetzt gleich der nächste ja ich fand es
ins wasser
ich hoffe die soll die glocken sich
gegenseitig jetzt ha ha ha ha wichtig
habe ich mit hh nein der geislinger
nicht an der typ war jetzt kommt er
wahrscheinlich noch auf mich nein habe
ich nicht dass er das problem ja aber
warum
aber das macht mir keinen links oder ich
habe aber auch keine feinde
ein kluger weg ich glaube eher der der
sieht ein dass er das irgendwie nicht
schafft und deswegen nimmt jetzt eine
angabe verschiedener stick der mixe aber
ich verstehe das nicht mein das ist
wer denkt dass wieder so krass wie doof
ist das immer direkt wenn ich mit ihm da
drin
oku
er liegt auf jeden fall so ein dings
brustpanzer den möchte ich auf jeden
fall machen ach so ja okay ich verstehen
ok ok alter die haben was ist das ja ich
mag das schon
nein auch etwa hat sich gestellt
aber man kann ich wollte ich war besser
als ich war besser als du ja ich hab
grad auf aber ich muss jetzt auch weg na
gut freunde das war es erst mal für
heute morgen geht's dann wieder ein pvp
video muss ich schauen was der mache und
dann geht es war morgens mit pcs weiter
muss verfolgt mich gefallen hat dürfte
gern eine positive bewertung abgeben
kanal von servern ekd es in der
beschreibung
willst du noch irgendwas sagen tschüss